time now for our scene an unseen segment
where we expose what's really behind the
big cultural stories of the day why
Facebook wants you to send them your
nude photos I can't believe we're even
doing this segment here to explain all
this is New York Times bestselling
author the wheel Wilder children's
series and Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo okay
what is the story Facebook wants your
nude photos they want your nude photos
preempted what do people have no well
that's a bigger question but they want
to fight revenge porn where people who
are in relationships post industry or
nude pictures of their partner when the
relationship ends I'll bet we could name
a few but you won't
here's what they want you to do submit
your photos the most secretive photos
you have to Facebook they then encrypt
them they take what they call a
fingerprint of the picture so not the
picture itself they say they don't store
the picture it'll be off the server in a
few days and they will then block that
image from ever being posted on Facebook
here's the problem Laura who's looking
at these images how long are they on the
server and the bigger question Facebook
had a 50 million person breach just last
year they admitted to in March they
admitted twice how sure we that they can
protect these images and that their
employees aren't copying them or they
are ongoing but if you haven't but what
if other people have new photos that's
not gonna help you give your photos that
you're keeping of yourself this whole
right bulb at photo segment forget seen
and unseen the end of civilization
segment Tommy make a new graphic okay we
should move on all right
mark man who's 30 years old oh my gosh
sued his parents or suicune by his
parents we call these people boomerang
brats you throw them out to the world
and they stay at he's a 30 year old he
says look I'm trying to be a father
here's a child of his own he said I'm
trying to be a father I need to live
with mom and dad
they gave him five notices to get out
five eviction notices they even deprived
food finally he sat with another network
and said this we have the audio
why couldn't you guys resolve this
without the court I would consider much
of what they were doing to try to get me
out as a tax 1/3 of Millennials Laura
all right hold the parents yeah the
parents were attacking him they asked
him to go get a job and get out get a
haircut
well looks like cousin is I mean that
was scary here's the scary thing a third
of Millennials are at home this one's
gone up from 25% Oh 34% of he's stroking
his hair he's stroking sir
he doesn't have money for a haircut
either well you know tough time that's
what you do to parent if your kid is
threatening to come home after went to
college or something turn the room into
a home gym with no couches well and then
the judge ordered them by the way the
judge has ruled the kids got a vacate
the man has to vacate and they're
calling for an investigation by Adult
Protective Services I hope that's for
the parent and not for the son now the
big story okay big story stormy Daniels
is getting a key to another two days no
no today she got the key to the city of
West Hollywood this is the mayor John
Doran listen as you know Lady Godiva
wrote naked through the streets of
England to protest injustice and taxes
and we have our own Lady Godiva here in
the City of West Hollywood
she's held her head up with dignity and
she's fought back and when she fights
back and mr. avenatti fights back
they're fighting back for all of us to
get our country back into our hands now
this is a city that did he use the word
dignity that they have asked do you
spend a lot of time in West Hollywood do
they do they've asked for impeachment
for Donald Trump and here's what I love
about this what's that mayor nothing
says you're being honored like getting a
key to the city in front of a sex shop
owned by a drag queen porn director this
is the level of honor bestowed on stormy
Daniels and the great star reacted this
way I'm not really sure what the key
opens I'm hoping it's the wine cellar
this community has a history of standing
up to bullies
speaking truth to power and I'm so very
very lucky to be a part of it you know
Laura they said she was a Profile in
Courage
she's a profile in cleavage I hope that
key opens the door to Talbots so we have
a full coverage but I just threw my blue
card in there we didn't even talk about
the new NFL policy no kneeling $20,000
penalty if any player does it for that
club this is gonna change things they
were losing money they had to do that
thanks Raymond great as always